For many years, one of the biggest criticisms
that I got from anybody, sales person that
worked for me was that I did not allow coffee
in our office.
When I tell you no coffee, I still don't drink
coffee, I don't like coffee.
And everybody used to give me a hard time.
"Pat, how is it possible.
You're OCD.
You do not like coffee.
How does a sales office not have coffee?"
For me, it's many different reasons.
One, I don't think we need coffee for energy.
I think our body needs to move for energy.
But stains bother me.
If I walk into a place with a stain, it bothers
me.
I can't work in an environment with stains
all over the carpet.
Well, years later, Mario, Alexis, Maral, and
many of the teammates came together, including
my wife, they came together and said, "We've
got to figure out a way to get Pat to have
a coffee machine."
So we had a coffee machine, and now that's
okay to have a coffee machine in the office.
But we added two other machines.
I decided to add an 88 wine bottle dispenser
that looks like of like this.
This is what it looks like.
You literally can walk in, in the middle of
the day while you're working, have a glass
of wine, and go back to your desk and we're
okay with that.
And Mario likes IPA beer and Tom likes Blue
Moon, so we also got a full on keg at the
office, with IPA and Blue Moon.
So if you want to have a IPA and Blue Moon
in the middle of the day, or two, or three,
if your name is Tom and Mario, they'll be
some incredible strategy sessions.
Earlier today, where am I going with this?
I'm talking about what today?
How to Change Your Mood in 5 minutes.
Because a glass of wine can change your mood
in five minutes, and provide better customer
service.
Earlier today, we were having an ideation
session in our office and things got a little
out of hand.
We saw a person, named Tom Ellsworth, that
probably shouldn't dance, was brave enough
to show us some of his incredible moves and
here's what it looked like.
[Tom dancing.]
So, Tom, I just want to give a toast to you.
May life be as rewarding as it was for us
while watching you perform that EPIC dance
move that I don't know many people can put
together.
If we got Justin Timberlake, if we got Chris.
. . if we got all of these guys together,
I don't know if they could put the moves together
like you just did.
You may have a career in choreography, but
I'm glad you're not choosing that route, and
you're going to be in business with us.
So, toast to you.
Now, with that being said, let me tell you
how you can change your mood, literally, in
five minutes.
I've been doing this for the last 15 years.
[I had to take a quick sip.]
So here's how simple it is.
Listen.
I will have, as a business owner, as an entrepreneur,
you go through a lot of different things.
People hit you, you know you get this, you
get that, and you know, cancellations, this
person, this employee's not happy, there's
an argument, there's a conflict, there's a
vendor issue, there's an attorney issue, there's
a lawsuit -- there's so many different things
that are going to hit you.
Right?
And if you don't know how to snap out of it
quickly, your day is gone.
And if your day is gone, your week is gone.
And if your week is gone, your month is gone,
then you're out of business.
So you've got to have a system.
Everything's about systems.
You've got to have a system.
So how do you change your mood in 5 minutes?
There's a couple of things you can do.
One of them is literally taking a walk, listen
to some music, the music that pumps you up,
and come back up.
Two is go do stairs.
Go step, go do two or three floors yourself
and you'll snap out of it in no time because
your body is moving, blood is flowing through
your body.
Three is literally watch a funny one-minute
video.
Watch a funny one-minute video that makes
you laugh and you will completely be out of
that state.
And four is my favorite system of all time.
And by the way, there's probably hundreds
of ways of doing this, and there are many
great ones.
I'm just giving you some basic ones that you
can implement today that can completely shift
your attitude.
Because the worst thing you can do is say,
"I'm going home."
That's what average people do, and they don't
make it.
"Today was a bad day, I'm going to go home
early."
Nope.
You cannot do that.
You will go out of business, your customers,
your team, your staff is depending on you
to show up even when you don't feel like it.
And they're hoping that you're a leader and
you have a system to snap out of it, to help
you out in business.
You know, what my favorite one is?
Here's what my favorite one is.
I've been using this for fifteen years.
When I was in the Army, and we were in boot
camp, one time I'll never forget, this man
who was 29 years old, I was 18, he got a letter
from his ex, at the time it was his wife,
and it was a letter, I mean, this is in boot
camp.
You can't call anybody.
The letter said that I'm leaving you, and
I'm leaving you for a man that you know of
as well.
And this guy wouldn't stop crying.
He would not stop crying.
He was so emotional, he was out of control.
So one, I'm sitting there myself, and I'm
concerned because I haven't seen my friends
for awhile, all my friends miss me, all this,
all that, all these things that I'm thinking
about myself, my little problem that I have
and here I see somebody that's going through
what they're going through, the issues that
they're going through, and I'm sitting there
telling myself, you know what Pat?
Snap out of it.
No matter what situation you're in, I promise
you, there are millions if not billions of
people that would love to change their massive
problem that they have -- the loss of a loved
one, you know, somebody completely breaking
their heart, losing everything, war, crime,
all this mess that they're going through,
there's a lot of people going through this.
They would love to exchange that with you.
Many people.
So #4 for me is to just kind of reflect and
sit there and say, listen, life is all good,
it's not as bad as you think it is, what can
I do today to solve this problem?
Now to give you the last one here, that was
the last one, but it's kind of leading to
the fifth one, here's the fifth one.
it works every single time.
Are you ready?
I'm in a bad mood, I had a bad conversation,
somebody upset me.
I will take five minutes and make a list of
five people.
I will literally make a list of five people.
Once I make a list of those five people, you
know what I do?
I call every one of those five people and
I tell them how amazing they are.
And I talk about their gifts.
I just want to tell you how grateful I am
for you.
I just want to tell you how much I love you.
I just want to tell you how amazing you are.
You're one of the most talented people I know
in this area.
I want to tell you you're one of the greatest
listeners I know.
You've got an incredible heart.
Five minutes later, everything is minuscule.
But here's the great thing.
You know what the great thing is?
you just impacted five people's day, and they
got changed because of you, and they're going
to be thinking about the impact you made in
their lives, and you're, in a way, you're
paying it forward.
So, whether it's a text, whether it's a letter,
whether it's a phone call, any of those methods,
where you are imposing your positive energy
to somebody else, indirectly, five times,
5X is coming back to you, making you feel
good because you're impacting the world in
a positive way.
So here's my challenge to you.
This is a shorter video.
Here's my challenge to you.
I want you to by the time you're done with
this video, stop whatever you're doing, even
if it's five minutes, stop and don't do anything
else, I want you to do this.
Make a list of five people's names.
Anybody.
Five of them.
Even if you think other people are watching
this and you are as well, don't worry about
it.
Make a list of five people, relative, friend,
business, coworker, client, it doesn't matter.
Five people.
And you know what I want you to do?
I want you to either make a call to them,
or text them, right now.
In a simple message, text or email.
Right now.
Tell them how special they are.
Talk about an experience with them that you
are extremely grateful for, lift them up.
Encourage them.
Tell them you believe in them.
And watch what happens with the response you
get.
And you tell me how you feel yourself.
And once you do, this is what I want you to
do.
I want you to comment on the bottom, and tell
us about your experience.
And tell us how fascinated these people were
to hear that message from you.
And with that being said, Mario, let's wrap
it up with this.
Hey, if you haven't subscribed to this channel,
please do so.
We're going to get to 100,000 subs by August
31.
If you haven't subscribed, click somewhere
around here to subscribe to this channel.
The #1 channel on YouTube for who, Mario?
[Mario: Entrepreneurs] the #1 channel on YouTube
for Entrepreneurs.
Let's see if I can get this up here.
Boom, okay, good catch.
Completely couldn't catch it .[Mario laughs
in the background.]
I forgot he's not 6'5".
It's okay, so, let us know how it went, message
on the bottom.
I'm really looking forward to the stories
you're going to be sharing with us, and if
you're watching this video on a completely
different website, always remember you can
come back to PatrickBetDavid.com, and questions,
comments, your experience, let us know.
Take care everybody.
Bye bye.